i think an important thing in any
learning strategy or any learning method
that we use
is
to do what we want to do hi there steve
kaufman here
today i want to talk about my strategy
for learning arabic and remember if you
enjoy my videos please subscribe click
on the bell for notifications
and if you follow me on i follow me on a
podcast service please leave a review
so arabic arabic spoken by i don't know
350 400 million people in the world an
area of the world that's often in the
news
i was very motivated to learn arabic but
i've been at it for quite a while and
i'm
probably not doing that well
and so i want to go over my strategy and
things that
maybe have changed in my strategy and
maybe my experience can be helpful to
other people
i will show you in my statistics at link
when i started with arabic
i will show you that i started arabic in
april of 2018
that not long thereafter i also started
learning persian
and not long after that i started
learning turkish so i had this strategy
of learning three major languages of the
middle east
my motivation was i started with hebrew
because my wife and i were visiting in
fact i did greek and hebrew because we
were going to visit crete and israel
then i went to jordan and i said there's
a lot more arabic speakers so i went and
and decided to learn arabic then i came
home and discovered that in vancouver we
have so many iranian immigrants here so
i decided to learn persian at the same
time
and then my wife was watching this
turkish miniseries on
netflix so i said why don't i go after
these three major languages of the
middle east
um
i dropped turkish
because written in the latin alphabet
it's in fact easier for me
a major obstacle in my arabic learning
is the writing system it's simply so
difficult for the brain to get used to a
different writing system so i decided to
focus on persian and arabic both of
which use the arabic script then the
other problem of course with arabic is
that
there is standard arabic which nobody
speaks as a native language but which is
the language used in you know education
in in political discussions on you know
television podcasts and so forth
uh most things are written in standard
arabic but if you go to lebanon or syria
or egypt not to mention morocco or iraq
or the persian gulf
people speak in various forms of arabic
and so i initially had the strategy of
focusing my arabic
effort on standard arabic
but then more recently i decided because
the movies are all from lebanon or from
egypt or sometimes from the gulf
uh and of course that's the language
that people speak that is the
conversational language so i said i
should try to learn those as well
so i had a tutor in uh egyptian arabic
in fact yeah one
and we have at link we have a number of
resources in both levantine and egyptian
arabic
but what i found after a while is that
by trying to speak egyptian arabic with
my egyptian arabic tutor
in the end i end up not being able to
speak anything
and so i had this experience the other
day and this is what sort of triggered
my decision to change my strategy which
i'm coming to
so i was actually cleaning my deck
because my deck i have a big wooden deck
i get a lot of you know
moss growing on it so i actually bought
a power washer great power washer it
took me quite a while to assemble it but
it works
uh and in the middle of doing that i
said i'm gonna go down i wasn't
confident the power washer would do the
job i'm gonna buy some vinegar and i'm
gonna scrub the duck as well with
vinegar and then i said i'll drop by
there's an area where there's like three
persian
uh stores one is a
guy who fixes this electronic equipment
and then there's a little place where
they sell kebabs and then there's a
coffee shop and there's a little patio
in between the three of them so i go
there so i walk into the coffee shop and
it's got the same name as the kebab shop
and i said are you connected yes so can
i eat here yes then i said salam
expecting to speak persian but she was
from lebanon so we spoke arabic
and i couldn't say anything in levantine
arabic
basically what came out was my standard
arabic
and she was very happy with my arabic
she told other people because they're
always very nice to you that how well i
speak arabic which isn't true of course
but i was surprised at how much i could
say in standard arabic even though i had
left it and was trying to learn egyptian
arabic now just
as a matter of
interest
uh people who walked into that oh and
this lady who was originally from
lebanon had lived in china but she
didn't speak chinese she'd lived in
sweden so he spoke in swedish and she
had some connection with russian which i
don't know but she spoke russian and lo
and behold some persian people came in
and we spoke persian and then another
person came in from moldova and we spoke
russian so i had a whole oh and there
was another gentleman sitting there who
had lived in korea and wanted to learn
languages and i persuaded him to join
link i had a great time but i walked
away from that saying the language the
arabic language that i've spent the most
time with the arabic language that i can
actually say something in is standard
arabic i not now know enough of egyptian
arabic and levantine arabic that some of
the things you know that they do says
you know ash ashan haik ashan hake
hashem keda uh you know the levantine
say she at the end of the sentence
instead of uh hal at the beginning to
introduce a question
uh you know
diluti or alatoul or all these things in
egyptian
uh
or in levantine i know enough of them
now that i can understand better if
someone is
kind of speaking mostly fossa but mixing
in a lot of dialect or a lot of regional
variations so i've kind of achieved what
i hope to achieve but i'm going to go
back to speaking standard arabic
mixing in a bit of egyptian or levantine
depending on the situation hoping to
understand and very often we pick up
from other people so if i'm speaking to
someone and i'm sort of mixing in it's a
bit like my portugal if i mix in a bit
of egyptian or levantine but stick to
what i know
i think that's going to enable me to
communicate so my strategy where i've
said initially i said you know stay with
fossa because i can listen to podcasts
then i said no i'm going to learn
you know egyptian or levantine and put
some effort into both of those and now
i'm saying
those are good
for comprehension and i'll make some of
those expressions in but basically i'm
going to stay with
standard arabic
so
i think an important thing in any
learning strategy or any learning method
that we use
is
to do what we want to do
the only thing that really matters in
language learning is the attitude of the
learner and the time we put in
so some people like flash cards some
people like anki some people like
duolingo it doesn't matter as long as
you enjoy what you're doing
you will improve as long as you're
putting in the time you'll do fine so on
that basis and and we can change i can
think that my i should be doing this in
arabic and then i change my mind the
other thing i would do now is i would
not attempt three languages at the same
time
uh because it means you're going to be
slowed down in each one of them
on the other hand i have a sense of
person i can actually converse in person
i can kind of converse in arabic and i
have a
bit of a sense of what turkish is all
about and
whatever i have put into those languages
it's not lost because if i go back to my
turkish which is the now the weakest of
the three very quickly will i get back
to where i was and then i can take it
forward so
it's not a i didn't make a mistake by
sort of dissipating my energies it just
meant that i didn't get as far in any
one of them as i would have been able to
do had i focused on just one so and i'm
going to leave you with a little walk
through of my statistics at link so that
you'll see
you know what the history has been of my
learning uh of those of those languages
and after that
uh i will leave a couple of videos that
you can go to
uh
to see
you know my arabic uh three years ago
and then two years ago maybe four years
ago and two years ago okay thank you for
listening bye for now well i thought i'd
have a look at what i've been doing in
arabic
this is my arabic page at link as it
looks right now
i've kind of been bouncing around i've
been
importing some articles i've been
looking at my jordanian cartoons
i watched a bit of this egyptian movie
then i go back to my mini stories in
standard arabic i've also done my mini
stories in egyptian arabic a little bit
in
it doesn't show here but in in levantine
arabic as well
and uh so i'm kind of a bit at loose
ends here
as i've explained in my video
but let's just look at at my history so
i think you know that if you click on
your
or you can even you know
do it this way hit the down arrow you
got to get to your profile and you can
see what your history has been so you
can see that i haven't been that active
this these past seven days however if i
go to my all-time statistics
i can see that
i started poking around at arabic
around the end of 2017 if i look at
known words if i look at known words
if i look at links created
i actually started
i guess you know poking around in 2017
but really my major effort was
early in 2018. that was a major spurt in
arabic
um and i've gone through phases as i
said
between my major initial effort in fusa
and more recently trying to get a
a bit of an exposure to levantine and
egyptian arabic
now
you'll see this day 2018
2018 april
if i look at my situation in
first of all the first semitic language
i started with was hebrew
uh because i was going to eat to israel
and i put some effort into hebrew but
when my wife and i ended up going to
jordan and i realized that actually
there's a lot more arabic speakers than
i dropped hebrew entirely i may go back
to it
but
so i started into my uh arabic and then
i came back to vancouver and lo and
behold there's far more persian speakers
here
so
again here by about you know the
i guess the beginning of 2019 i was
putting more effort
into persian than into arabic and so i
kind of kept my persian activities going
alongside my
arabic if i go back to where my arabic
was
you see that i've kind of kept them both
going and going simultaneously the other
thing that i did
was i decided to
you know i'm interested in the middle
east and my wife is watching
series on netflix in turkey turkish so
by the middle of 2019 i put a
three-month stint into learning turkish
so a lot of distraction
from
my
arabic learning
so i just want to show you that as a
sort of
some background to
what i
was talking about
in my
uh
video on my arabic learning strategy and
and uh
you know i will leave you with two
videos
that you can watch to see how well i did
at two different stages
in my arabic learning